um yesterday uh or late the day before
a 12-page letter was released to the
media supposedly written by donald trump
weighing in on the trump riot committee
hearings now i don't believe for a
second that donald trump really wrote a
12-page letter trump doesn't write and
trump doesn't read all he's capable of
as far as we've seen
is um tweet style messages often with
strange grammar spelling and syntax so i
don't believe trump wrote a 12-page
letter but i do believe that trump sat
somewhere and told someone what to write
and chris seliza from cnn received the
letter and gave us a list of the
wackiest things
and uh here are some some key key
moments from this statement that shows
us how the right is thinking of these
hearings number one if they had any real
evidence they'd hold real hearings with
equal representation remember
republicans opted out of that there was
a framework for an actual bipartisan
committee ten members five republicans
five democrats democratic chair
republican vice chair and both the chair
and vice chair have to agree on every
subpoena republicans rejected it so
democrats did what they could which is
they've got liz cheney and adam
kinzinger on the panel so that that's
their fault two they used the illegally
constituted committee to put on a smoke
and mirrors show for the american people
in a pitiful last-ditch effort to
deceive the american public again
there's nothing illegal about the
committee just nothing we've had other
committees the benghazi one we've had
others perfectly legal number three
they've refused to allow their political
opponents to participate in the process
they've excluded exculpatory witnesses
and anyone who so easily points out the
flaws in their story again as chris
eliza writes republicans uh crushed the
actual bipartisan committee that they
wanted to do that it is because of
republicans
that they um
don't have more republicans on the
committee and also
a whole bunch of the pro-trump people
that were subpoenaed didn't go and
that's now the subject of legislation
that includes steve bannon and peter
navarro
four the unselect pseudo committee has
coordinated with their media puppets to
broadcast their witnesses on tv without
opposition cross-examination or rebuttal
evidence again
more than a thousand depositions were
taken of all sorts of witnesses it is
untrue that that is what was done
uh and then a whole bunch of other just
repetition of lies i won't look at all
of these but number seven is they
illegally inflated voter rules that's
unproven they illegally allowed
harvested and stuffed ballots no
evidence of that they abused the use of
mail-in ballots that's there's no
evidence of that they physically removed
republicans from counting facilities
that that's untrue now there are random
republicans who showed up demanding to
oversee the election who were not
allowed to because there's a process for
establishing observers there there were
republican and democratic observers
there were people who just showed up
demanding access
it's sort of like if i go you know if i
go to a court and i say i want to sit uh
alongside the judge
they would say well no you're you
haven't been selected you're not the
judge in the same way if i'm not
actually an election observer i don't
have a right to just show up and uh be
given power there but there is no
evidence for any of those claims
um and a whole bunch of other stuff that
doesn't really have any meaning like
donald trump writing in this letter on
election night america watched as my
lead grew and grew over biden as i was
set to claim another victory we expected
the red mirage we expected that the
early vote would favor trump and that as
the cities were counted overnight and
into the next day
it would start to point more in the
direction of joe biden all of these
things we expected so
i don't believe
trump wrote this but i do believe he had
input and it really shows us that they
aren't changing their talking points
every day that passes we have more of an
empirical basis to reject their claims
but they continue making the exact same
claims day after day after day now at
the end of the day
i don't know that these hearings are
really going to have any impact they're
getting an okay audience my guess is the
people watching are mostly the people
who already don't believe the things
that donald trump has been saying so
whether these hearings will have any
impact whatsoever remains to be seen but
the
the lies that they are telling continue
to be the exact same lies and at this
point i don't know who's falling for
them we'll have more on this on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show will be back right after
this short break
many of us know what it's like to have
acne show up when we least want it to
you should have seen me in middle school
now i'm on camera and i really do the
best i can to keep my skin clear and for
that i go to apostrophe our sponsor on
the apostrophe website you just answer a
few questions take a couple pictures of
your skin and then you have a virtual
visit with a board certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan they quickly
ship you the prescription medication i
can tell you that when it comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me
apostrophe makes it simple and quick
i've had a great experience with
apostrophe myself you get affordable
quality medical treatment from a
licensed dermatologist and prescription
meds that actually work but i can do it
all on my phone i don't have to spend
hours in a doctor's office
my audience gets 15 off your first
dermatology visit go to apostrophy.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description